inbound marketing refers to the
activities that you do in the contents
that you create that drives people to
come to you and engage with your site
your product or your social channels
rather than having to go out and get
people's attention by ads or other
outbound marketing activities you're
earning the attention of your customers
and drawing them in by producing
interesting content now you want to
personalize your content to the needs
and wants of your target audience and
you're going to want to have a
multi-channel mindset here with inbound
marketing you're going to need to
connect with your users where are they
are and where they want you to connect
with them whether that be by using your
blog publishing things on social media
your SEO search results or even emails
you send out now one thing that's really
important with inbound marketing and
frankly with all of your marketing
efforts it's making sure you're
publishing the right content to the
right people in the right place at the
right time this intersection will allow
your marketing efforts to be helpful in
relevant rather than annoying and
repetitive let's go to Greg to talk
about his thoughts on inbound marketing
my name is Greg bronner I am head of
marketing at Udacity and I've been in
marketing for about 15 years inbound
marketing is a set of activities that
you take to engage with your audience to
get them to come to your site directly
these are these are things like blog
posts social posts things on Facebook
LinkedIn and Twitter that you engage
direct with your audience and get them
to come to your site so the content the
traction easier side is going to have to
be relevant so for example in Udacity
case we provide an education platform
and an education service for you to come
and learn from us if we were to post
things related education that shows that
thought leaders are knowing exactly what
we're talking about the education space
or relevant to topics that they're
interested in the more likely to come to
us so being an educational platform we
send out things that are related to
their the continuing education for them
things that we're launching that are new
things are really relevant to why they
came to us in the first place we started
out saying things about cats and muscle
cars it's really not what they want to
hear from us and look Norris pretty
quickly or wonder what the heck we're
doing over here so we look at creating
different types of content what you
really want to understand is what type
of content your audience really wants to
engage with there's everything from
webcast to infographics to memes but you
have to pick the right one for you and
your audience because they're going to
want to consume in a certain way the
best way to do that is back to a/b
testing is to go ahead and send out to
for messages sent on to infographic one
month and I mean the next month and a
vine the third month see what gets the
highest engagement and then from there
you can refine your marketing plan to
determine what kind of inbound contact
you want to spend time on so we look at
creating content you want to make sure
you're hitting the right people with the
right content in the right place at the
right time you look at facebook versus
twitter it's a great example of how you
engage your audience's differently on
facebook you can post long-form content
and engage in a very deep discussion
with your with your customers on twitter
it's a shorter medium right to only 140
characters so you have to really be
thoughtful about what you post and try
and get them back to your site and
engage with you there so when you look
at good quality content and creating the
quality content you want to do it
yourself if you can you can control the
message the theme the colors that images
and it's something that really ties to
you and your company if you buy content
or syndicate someone else's content you
don't always get what you really want
I'm virgin america right now is doing an
amazing job with their content creation
of their marketing it's unique its
original it's definitely to their brand
I encourage you to check out their
billboards and their their website
they've done an amazing job in creating
a fun airline and a space where it's
really not a lot of fun to fly you look
at creating a blog in a follower of
readership there which you really want
to do is have a Content calendar look
out a month or two months of what you
want to write what you want to talk
about and then figure out how to get
that content created so again we're
talking about original content what you
want to have is someone creating it for
you in a way that tells your story
that's the best way to create any type
of sort of blog following I would say
when you look at publishing on social
you really have to pay attention to what
channels you want to engage with and
have time to engage with when you look
at LinkedIn or Twitter or Facebook which
is three kind of big ones right now they
all have their different ways if people
want to interact and they want to hear
back from you as well so example on
Twitter don't just post stuff and never
go back to it again you want to actually
engage because people retweet you
they'll talk to you ask you questions
make sure if you do engage in social you
have time to nurture and gauge a
community the way that they want to talk
to you